a Canadian junior hockey player involved
in a deadly bus crash is making a
triumphant return to the ice
Ryan's pres netsky was paralyzed from
the chest down when his team's bus
crashed in April 16 people died
including many of his teammates but less
than four months later the 19 year old
is ready to compete again Don Dahler
shows us how stress new skis
determination got him back on the ice
Don good morning good morning after
learning he might never walk again
stretch knit ski told his dad he was
determined to continue his athletic
career by playing sledge hockey given
the extent of his injuries few people
could have expected he'd come so far so
soon at a hockey rink outside Calgary
Ryan stressed miski skates effortlessly
onto the ice it was his first day
learning to play sledge hockey a sport
designed for people with physical
disabilities for Ryan this day has been
a dream of his since learning he was
paralyzed from the chest down I just
wanted to be on the ice I knew my legs
aren't gonna work for however long if I
don't heal but just being on the ice it
would be amazing Ryan was a defenseman
playing his first season with the
Humboldt Broncos in Saskatchewan Canada
the team was traveling to a hockey game
in a neighboring town all I remember was
the bus driver screaming and something
pulling in front of us and kind of
blacked out from there and then woke up
against a semi truck looking at the the
mayhem and you know my first instinct
was to get up and help my teammates and
my brothers and I couldn't move did you
know there was something seriously wrong
yeah it was in a lot of pain and the
only thing I could do was scream for
help but it was tough because I had
broken ribs punctured lung but I mean I
did what I could to help a tractor
trailer collided with the team bus on an
isolated stretch of highway 16 of the 29
people on board were killed in the crash
a few days later Ryan's dad told CBS
this morning about the moment his son
found out that he might never walk again
when they told us
Oh Ryan just looked at us and goes dad
Olympic sledge hockey and get us the
gold are you kidding me no I couldn't
fall apart there had to be strong for
him but just that kids amazing but the
road back to the hockey rink has been
difficult Ryan suffered four broken ribs
serious head trauma a lacerated spleen
and two shattered vertebra after a
six-hour surgery in Canada
Ryan was flown to the Shriners Hospital
in Philadelphia which specializes in
spinal cord injuries when he arrived
Ryan spoke to reporters from a stretcher
still unable to move I just keep my
teammates in my heart to know everyday
set new goals and challenges and I just
remind myself that I do it for them
Ryan's rehabilitation began that same
day the doctors first priority was to
help him adjust a life in a wheelchair
then Ryan's athletic skills were put to
an even greater test with an intensive
program of physical rehabilitation which
included time in the water on the
treadmill and even upper body workouts
there's lots of like muscle
strengthening because my left side was
weaker than my right and I did a lot of
weights and training and now it's
starting to get stronger so I can last
longer in my wheelchair less than a
month after not being able to move Ryan
was strong enough to join his teammates
in Las Vegas for a reunion
shortly after he was a guest of the
Philadelphia Flyers at their training
facility now Ryan is back playing the
sport that he loves doing what comes
naturally moving forward in body and
spirit I just want to say thank you and
you know I'm stay strong
you know life life will get you down but
as long as you you know keep that
positive mentality anything I think is
possible in July the driver of the
tractor-trailer that allegedly caused
the crash was charged with 16 counts of
dangerous driving causing death a court
date is scheduled for later this month
John thank you wow
Ryan is amazing what am i attitude and
spirit that guy and you know we've
talked so much about resilience it's key
yeah of survival right and hope